and I'm telling you AI is the
opportunity that you've been waiting for
but you have to make a move given how
much AI has already altered our systems
over the next few years I'm expecting it
to majorly accelerate our ability to
test and learn not just here in society
and whoever learns the fastest is going
to win this is all happening in plain
sight everyone's talking about AI I know
this isn't the first time you're hearing
about it but to take advantage of this
moment I need you to do three Simple
Things One reframe your thinking around
AI don't see it as the enemy see it as a
tool it really is a phenomenal tool
you're not going to be replaced by AI at
least not yet you're going to be
replaced by a human using AI so please
be that human that's replacing other
people to do that you need to to figure
out how AI is going to disrupt you face
it head on don't run don't hide identify
your vulnerabilities and three identify
all of the AI tools that are relevant to
you and master them learn absolutely
everything you can hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I quit on
my business partner I struggled to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today let's learn how you
can use AI to get ahead While others
Panic enjoy
remember this is the very beginning of a
very aggressive and fast-moving
Revolution moving quickly gives you two
advantages number one you can rock it
ahead of other people by mastering the
tools and if you master the tools people
are going to turn to you because you're
able to more efficiently solve problems
going back to the Elon Musk quote if you
can solve harder problems faster you're
going to get paid more and in these
early days where most people are stuck
in the deer in headlights mode you have
an unfair Advantage the second thing is
While others are caught between
Fascination and panic you can be
voraciously acquiring skills and growing
more useful so take action now start
mastering the technology while everybody
else is absolutely playing around with
AI dismissing AI fighting against it or
running in fear if you embrace it you
can create a skill set moat around you
and leverage your knowledge to get paid
more or to build something that wasn't
even previously possible the the second
advantage that AI gives you is an almost
unimaginable amount of efficiency in
certain tasks it is insane the things
you can do if you've seen it in action
it is breathtaking how fast it will come
up with answers I had it recently for a
holiday party I had it generate a quiz
based on the most popular movies and
songs and it did it literally in sex
gave me a hundred different questions
and answers now don't get me wrong AI is
not a Panacea there are plenty of
problems that right now ai sucks at Sam
Altman the founder of openai the maker
of the ubiquitous chat GPT has himself
said that people are getting so hyped up
that they're going to be disappointed if
you think that this is Terminator 2
already and chat jpt is going to turn
into liquid metal and save you from some
space aliens yes you're going to be
disappointed but if on the other hand
you look at AI as an efficiency tool
that needs to be wielded by a very
capable and well-trained human you're
going to dunk on everyone AI can already
write articles create social posts
generate images make videos generate
human speech summarize books or emails
and everything in between create
transcripts of speech allow you to edit
speech by editing the text of the
transcript Yes you heard that right you
could edit what I'm saying right now
just by editing the transcript I know
because we're working on integrating
that into our pipeline here as we speak
I had to create a verbal disclaimer
acknowledging that I knew a replica of
my voice was being generated just three
months ago this was something that was
too expensive for us to do and now it's
readily available that's how fast things
are moving here's the thing about AI
that most people are missing which is
why they're standing still right now and
why I hope you won't AI is about
efficiency and Rapid iteration the whole
way to get ahead in life is what I call
the physics of progress which is all
about trying something and learning and
in fact when I'm teaching people it I
often tell it this is like learning like
Ai and now you have ai at your
fingertips to speed that up legendary
futurist Ray Kurzweil predicts that this
is all moving so fast that by the year
2045 we will reach what he calls the
technological singularity he defines
that as the moment when technology
advances so fast that we can no longer
predict where things are headed let me
be clear I can never guarantee that I'm
seeing things correctly I could be wrong
I don't have race track record but I do
know that you've got nothing to lose by
learning and you could have a whole lot
to gain by implementing so my advice is
to prepare now and take Massive Action I
always tell people action cures all for
example I think there are a few people
more worried about AI than Elon but what
was his response the best way to control
the future is to invent it he invested a
billion dollars into open Ai and is busy
at work building AI systems to Pilot
both robots and cars that to me is how
you respond even if this is the bad kind
of interesting time don't just sit back
take action learn build create leverage
Ai and see what you can do together I
think you'll be surprised rule number
two is leverage AI for your business
with Alex hermosi AI is going to be the
biggest shift in our lifetime it is the
equivalent in my opinion of the moon
landing except the only difference is
that it will actually change all of our
Lives rather than just being a picture
to say that we won the Cold War
different than the internet phone
systems television because what those
did was they reshuffled the workforce
this has the ability to remove or
eliminate the workforce altogether
cryptocurrencies in general have the
potential to overturn the financial
institution AI is the potential to
overturn the Human Institution I try to
convince people to slow down slow down
AI to regulate AI
I tried for years I think you have to
watch this clip because it will make
everything about the same make sense so
this is from Google and this is from
four years ago their personal assistant
Ai and they haven't released this to the
public which is weird
sure give me one nothing
first name is Lisa
okay perfect so I will see Lisa at 10
o'clock on May 3rd okay great thanks
great have a great day bye that's the
Baseline that was four years ago now
imagine it was a sales call and we have
sales AI That's listened to 10 million
sales calls this is the types of things
that these people say in these
situations I will say the same thing and
then iterates and learns over and over
again the AI can live a million
lifetimes in terms of the amount of
volume it can churn through and process
and learn from compared to a human so
the best sales guy is going to have this
much experience compared to the best AI
sales guy and so if it can have those
calls 24 hours a day in real time to
whatever Prospect you want you may even
imagine a world where you ask the phone
teller hey are you a human and when they
say no I'm AI you're relieved because
you're like thank God I'm talking to the
best version of this who can handle my
problem right now so if you were to ask
people what jobs do you think AI will
replace first most people said first
it'll replace the low skill jobs the
physical labor and then it'll be the low
skilled White Collar jobs and then it'll
be the high school White Collar jobs
like programmers and coders and then
finally maybe it'll replace the creative
jobs but what's interesting is that it
actually happened in the reverse order
if you're a copywriter this has serious
implications for you a logo designer
this has serious implications for you
customer service 24 hours a day in real
time immediate feedback what happens to
all the Physicians it becomes immediate
and more accurate for us to have access
to a medical AI from our homes and it
can see us because it can interpret data
visually too if you're in finance it
will be able to take all of the raw data
and realign it and put it into beautiful
Excel sheets A friend of mine has a
father who's a medical malpractice
attorney he asked it to write an
argument for why malpractice should not
be capped in terms of how much a lawyer
can make on a malpractice suit and then
it outlined an entire argument for why
it should be uncapped it happened to be
almost identical to the argument that he
had after four years of experience you
see videos like this you see all these
people on YouTube you see Instagram
posts well what if the AI reads every
single Instagram post of all time and
ranks them by highest performing and
then merge that with video and deep
fakes we will have pundits and
influencers that don't exist list
imagine you could create the perfect
celebrity or the perfect spokesperson or
the perfect porn star and with deep
fakes they can work 24 hours a day say
exactly what you want and what they say
has the perfect tone and me to just
stimulate the sh out of our dopamine
centers and we're just going to be
plugged in because it knows what we like
better than we do if you don't believe
me go to this person does notexist.com
and just keep refreshing it and it will
show you new people now if you remember
earlier a video is made of multiple
images put together back to back to back
if it can make an image of a real person
it can make many images of real people
if they can make many images of real
people it can make a video of a real
person and then we'll have questions of
verification did President Biden say
that did President Trump say that or is
it a deep fake the blue check mark will
take on an entirely new meaning in the
very near future now those are just a
few a few use cases but anywhere humans
are it will disrupt if you are connected
to the AI you can input faster and you
can get information back faster because
you're not limited by your digits this
will be the next order of magnitude in
terms of output and value that
individuals be able to create in the
economy rule number three is use Ai
smartly and safely with Jordan Peterson
can you comment on your thoughts about
artificial intelligence and what it
means for Humanity
foreign
the bigger the toy the smarter you
better be to use it
so that's and that's worth thinking
about because we're coming up with some
pretty damn big toys and one of my
friend Jonathan pajo said again he said
recently he's I told you about him this
deep deep religious thinker he's
something
he said we're going to see giants walk
the earth again
and you think well what does that mean
it's like well
we're already Androids you know
already
when you're on Twitter you're an Android
well why
well you know there are lots of trolls
on Twitter
sometimes I'm one of them by the way
but I'm not an anonymous troll
so I take my lumps let's say
well I started calling the trolls troll
demons and uh I had a reason for that
and the reason is you know maybe you're
some resentful character who's a coward
and and you're Machiavellian and
narcissistic and Psychopathic and
sadistic because that's actually the
Hallmarks of anonymous trolls and that's
been studied very well by people who
study the so-called dark tetrad of
personality traits I interviewed this
guy Dale paulus who's the head
researcher among the dark dark tetrad
research group and that'll be coming out
right away and it's clearly the case
that the anonymous denigrating trolls
are Psychopathic Machiavellian
narcissistic sadists and maybe not right
to the clinical point but enough so that
you can detect it using the proper
psychometric measurement instruments and
so you think you got this resentful you
know underground character who's carpent
away on Twitter trying to do nothing but
cause trouble who's also Anonymous and
he's bitter and he wants to hurt people
and he likes to hurt people which is
what lulls means right I'm doing it for
the lulls means I'm doing it
because I positively Delight in the
production of human misery and you think
if you just met that guy you wouldn't
give him a half a second of your time in
fact he wouldn't even meet him because
he's cowering in his mother's basement
covered with Cheeto dust under the
covers you know and he's just he's just
there's nothing to him at all except
bitterness and spite but now you
multiply him 10 million times and you
make him electronic
and that's an Android and that's what
happens every time he posts something on
Twitter and she's not it's it's he's
already a human machine hybrid and he's
a human super intelligent connected
machine hybrid and so that means all his
pathology is Multiplied immensely by our
Tech by our technological might and I've
thought recently that virtualization
enables psychopathy so in normal social
situations if you're a narcissistic
Machiavellian and you push it too hard
someone will absolutely hit you and that
will be the end of it and most of the
time it's cowards who take that route
and it doesn't take much intimidation to
stop them just the hint of appropriate
just retaliation will keep them silent
but online especially if you're
anonymous that's all Stripped Away and
so the psychopath can have free reign
and part of the reason that our culture
is being torn apart at the moment is
because virtualization enables
psychopathy and so that's a big problem
and so that all pertains to this
question of well you know when you have
bigger toys you better be a bigger boy
and that's something Carl Jung commented
on in detail in his writing he thought
that
he studied Alchemy you know thousands of
years of alchemical writing the
Alchemists were motivated by the idea
that there was a substance that was
material
and if we could investigate material and
discover that substance we would live
forever we wouldn't be ill and we could
transmute base Metals into gold which
would be infinitely wealthy and Jung's
notion was
that the promise of matter was what
impelled Alchemy and out of that grew
science and science is motivated by the
notion that if we study matter deeply
enough we'll prolong life will increase
health and will make ourselves wealthy
and of course that's exactly what
happened and we took this technological
route there so out of alchemy this weird
dreamlike mythology emerge science and
just blew up and made us into
technological Giants but there was an
ethic in alchemy too that was Allied in
part
complexly with the whole judeo-christian
tradition there was an ethic and it
didn't expand at the same rate and so
now we're you know we're primitive
children on the ethical front with the
tools of gods and that's very very
dangerous and in fact it might be
fatally dangerous and so one of the
things that Jung attempted to do in his
work was to help people understand that
it was necessary for us to take on an
ethical responsibility that was
commensurate with our technological
power
and that that would require something
like a
something like the deepest of all
possible religious revaluations right
the revaluation of Good and Evil to use
the nietzschean phrase as an as of what
medication for the death of God is very
serious set of ideas and
you think we're powerful now man you
wait till the AI giant starts to stroll
around the earth and that's coming like
you will absolutely see that in your
lifetime you'll probably see it in the
next two or three years because that
technology is moving so quickly that
even those who are on top of it can't
keep up
so and I would say we better get our act
together because we could make this
world quite the Heavenly place but
there's a lot more Pathways to Hell than
there are to have it also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is solve real world
problems with Elon Musk it feels like at
some point in the last year
seeing the progress on understanding
that you that the AI the Tesla AI
understanding the world around it led to
a kind of an aha moment because you
really surprised people recently when
you said
probably the most important product
development going on at Tesla this year
is this robot Optimus yes many companies
out there have tried to put out these
robots have been working on them for
years and so far no one has really
cracked it there's no Mass adoption
robot in people's homes there are some
in in manufacturing but it like I would
say no one's kind of really
cracked it what is it something that
happened in the development of full
self-driving that gave you the
confidence to say you know what we could
do something special here
yeah exactly so you know it took me a
while to sort of realize that that in
order to solve self-driving you really
needed to solve real world AI
um at the point of which you solve real
world AI for a car which is really a
robot on four wheels you can then
generalize that to a robot on legs as
well the two hard Parts I think like
it's not it obviously companies like
Boston Dynamics have shown that it's
possible to make uh quite compelling
sometimes alarming robots right um you
know so so this is from a sensors and
actuator standpoint it's certainly uh
been demonstrated by many that it's
possible to make a humanoid robot the
thing that the things that are currently
missing are enough intelligence enough
intelligence for the robot to navigate
the real world and do useful things
um without being explicitly instructed
so so the missing things are basically
real world uh intelligence and uh
scaling up manufacturing um those are
two things that Tesla is very good at
and uh so then we basically just need to
design the the specialized actuators and
sensors that are needed for a human-like
robot people have no idea this is this
is going to be bigger than the car
so let's dig into exactly that I mean in
one way it's actually an easier problem
than full self driving because you
instead of an object going along at 60
miles an hour which if it gets it wrong
well someone will die this is an object
that's engineered to only go what three
or four or five miles an hour walking
speed basically and so a mistake isn't
there aren't lives at stake there might
be embarrassment at Stakes yeah it
doesn't take it over and uh
right and murderous in our sleep or
something rule number five is CA AI as a
tool with Neil deGrasse Tyson a lot of
people's concern is it's going to
replace jobs for copywriters a lot of
Silicon Valley people are like for
example the store that came out with New
York Times type in New York Times gbt
and I put code red New York Times gbt
code red okay so this is a recent
article right there a new chat about is
a code red for Google search business
okay A lot of people are talking about
how this new wave of chat bot like chat
gbt using AI could reinvent or even
replace traditional internet search
engine okay so what's your point I'm
excited okay that's they're saying okay
I think it's exciting I would say yeah
by the way and one time I I tweeted this
I said
um
people who cheat on exams do so
because the system values your grade
more than the student values learning
okay so if we're worried that people
will create a a a paper in in whatever
whatever oh there it is thank you you
found 2013. yeah yeah no I've been I've
been at this thank you you'll be the
10-year anniversary of that thought
because our school system values grades
more than students value learning that's
such a powerful tweet yeah so the point
is why why would you cheat at all right
if it's only to get a grade so that the
school system thinks more highly of you
when being in school is about learning
yeah and so if you have the AI bot
create your papers you didn't learn a
thing but you got the grade this is this
is the problem we began with here in
this conversation the the value we put
on a grade is out of proportion with who
and what you actually are and become in
life so so yeah you can submit papers
like that fine
but you'll be an idiot at the end of
your school you'll get a degree because
this you fooled the system but did you
fool yourself did you fool your life no
you don't you didn't
and here's another Point guessing on an
exam
okay
uh yeah that works sometimes okay
because you might be right but guessing
in real life just shows your ignorance I
see AI as a helpful tool when you can't
otherwise get something done as well as
you could if if but not as a replacement
for your own learning I don't see that
you don't think you think AI will ever
replace you
some tax of mine for sure will it not
replace well will it not replace what
will it not replace specific to you I'm
specifically talking to Neil deGrasse
Tyson what can you do that AI in the
future won't be able to replace I don't
know okay it's possible that AI will
replace everything about me that's
entirely possible however
however tomorrow I might go to the
Bahamas and meet someone new the AI
didn't do that that person might give me
new insights in my life that didn't
happen to the AI I will have new
thoughts because of that experience than
the AI had so the AI will be Frozen with
whatever was my last published
searchable content on the internet
if I have thoughts that I write down by
hand and they're not on the internet
right and I have enlightened ideas the
AI will not be able to track that unless
I post it online which I might then do
then it'll catch up with me they're fine
do you think everything under the sun uh
uh has been thought of and written about
online no of course not oh my gosh of
course not okay new ideas are not yet
online so I'd like to see AI invent new
understandings of the laws of physics I
haven't seen that yet okay you know what
that's a good way of uh think about it I
I that makes sense because meaning human
beings working together in a
collaborative way invent things AI
hasn't had hasn't independently yet
invented something big but people who
claim that General AI will one day
arrive there and okay fine but here's uh
something else sure uh on the back of my
phone is a
a section of
Van Gogh's The Starry Night okay uh
you could tell AI
to paint something in the style of Van
Gogh of this scene and they'll do it
but you can't tell AI to be Van Gogh in
the first place
does it need to yes why because that's
the style that van Gogh pioneered
did you get my point so uh
it's not going to be Van Gogh it can ape
the style of Van Gogh because it has
data on that it doesn't have data on
something that hasn't happened yet
this painting had not happened before he
painted it and his entire style of
painting had not really happened yes
it's impressionist but his is distinct
is the AI going to give me something
distinct that no one has happened yet
that isn't aping anybody else's style
maybe that day will come and maybe we'll
appraise it but that we're not there yet
and rule number six the last home before
some very special bonus Clips is improve
Humanity with Stephen Hawking everything
that Civilization has to offer is a
product of human intelligence we cannot
predict what we might achieve when this
intelligence is Amplified by such rule
say I may provide but the eradication of
War disease and poverty would be high on
anyone's list success in creating AI
would be the biggest event in human
history unfortunately that might also be
the last unless we learn how to avoid
the risks in the near term for example
World militaries are considering
starting an arms race in autonomous
weapon systems that can boost and
eliminate their own targets while the UN
is debating really Banning such weapons
autonomous weapons proponents usually
forget to ask the most important
question what is the likely end point of
an arm's race and is that desirable from
the human race do we really want cheap
AI weapons to become the kalashnikovs of
Tomorrow soul to criminals and
terrorists on the black market give you
concerns about long-term controllability
a better more advanced AI systems should
we earn them and turn over our defense
to them in 2010 computerized trading
systems created a stock market flash
crash what would a computer trigger
crash look like in the defense Arena the
best time to stop the autonomous weapons
arms races now in the medium term AI May
automate our jobs to bring both great
Prosperity inequality looking further
ahead there are no fundamental Mr what
can be achieved there is no physical law
precluding particles from being
organized in ways that perform with more
advanced computations than the
arrangements of particles in human
brains an explosive transition if
possible although it may play out
differently than in the movies as
surfing good realized in 1965 machines
with superhuman intelligence could
repeatedly improve their design even
further triggering what Werner Vince
called a singularity one can imagine
such technology outsmarting financial
markets out inventing human researchers
out manipulating human leaders and
potentially subtunious lit weapons we
cannot even understand whereas a
short-term impact of AI depends on who
controls it the long-term impact depends
on whether it can be controlled at all
in short the Advent of super intelligent
AI who would be either in the best or
the worst thing ever to happen to
humanity so we should plan ahead if a
superior alien civilization sent us a
text message saying we'll arrive in a
few decades what we just replied okay
call us when you get here we'll leave
the lights on probably not but this is
more or less what has happened with AI
little serious research has been devoted
to these issues outside a few small
non-profit institutes fortunately this
is now changing technology Pioneers Elon
Musk Bill Gates and Steve Wozniak have
echoed my concerns on a healthy culture
of risk assessment and awareness of
societal implications that's beginning
to take root in the AI Community many of
the world's leading AI researchers
recently signed an open letter calling
for the goal of AI to be redefined from
Simply creating raw and directed
intelligence to creating intelligence
directed at benefiting Humanity the
future of Life Institute where I serve
on the scientific Advisory board has
just launched a global research program
aimed at keeping AI beneficial when we
invented fire we messed up repeatedly
then invented the fire extinguisher with
more powerful Technologies such as
nuclear weapons synthetic biology and
strong artificial intelligence we should
instead plan ahead a name to get things
right the first time because it may be
the only chance we will get I am an
optimist and don't believe in boundaries
neither for what we can do in our
personal lives nor for what life and
intelligence can accomplish in our
universe this means that a brief history
of intelligence that I have told you
about is not the end of your story but
just the beginning of what I hope will
be millions of years of life flourishing
in the cosmos our future is a race
between The Growing Power of our
technology and the wisdom with which we
use it let's make sure that wisdom wins
in fact right now we're all going to
make a promise to ourselves you can do
it silently we don't have to have
everybody shouting it out
but you're going to make a promise to
yourself right now because if if you
follow through with what we're about to
say everything will be different if you
failed to do this you'll come back a
year from now and you're going to write
the same on the wall I promise
because this is the part that you have
to break out of make yourself a promise
right now that you will
disengage your sense of self your sense
of self-worth
from Achievement
and you're going to marry that
to Pursuit
Once You Are Holy focused on sincere
Pursuit everything changes when you're
focused on outcome when you're saying to
yourself I want to get rich I want to
win the Academy Award ah those are my
dreams it's an end state right it
doesn't work like here's one of those
things things become trite because
they're so true so please for the love
of God don't make people repeat the most
obvious ever like money can't buy
happiness
okay money can't buy happiness it can
buy a lot of cool
it bought me a really nice house
in fact baby show the photo yeah
we actually own part of that jet company
I'm not joking how crazy is that we know
the CEO there was one time where I was
trying to get on the flight they were
giving me I can't remember why and
I called the CEO up and I was like yo
you need to talk to your gate agent
like that's money
it's bananas
money is better than you think it is
more powerful than you think but it is
not at all what you've been told money
solves money problems and that's awesome
and there's a lot of cool stuff that you
can do with money there's no joke so we
run impact Theory out of our house our
house is like 10 000 square feet
swimming pool balconies all that crazy
one of our rooms is actually called like
actually when we bought the house they
called it this it's called the great
room
and that thing is big
I'm not joking we once played um Nerf
with Nerf guns we did like a whole hide
and seek capture the flag thing in the
house it was crazy
so money does really extraordinary
things people will chase money forever
because money actually has utility so I
am not the guy that's saying oh money
doesn't matter or money's not a thing or
money's not worth a Pursuit what I am
saying though money really can't buy
happiness the very thing you're pursuing
in your life is very simple it is
fulfillment that's it now I sum up
fulfillment very simply how do you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
do you feel good do you feel like you're
making the most of your life are you
tapping into what the Greeks call Techni
are you working your ass off and that's
a key component is it hard are you
working your ass off
sad but true are you working your ass
off for a set of skills
this is oh you this is the angry face
this this is this is about tapping into
rage we talked about that Elizabeth not
at rage yet we'll get there
but there we go
so you really have to
work hard
for a set of skills
that matter to you now the skills have
to matter
that's a key part of the equation
once the skills matter to you and they
allow you to serve not only yourself but
other people and then you actually go
and serve those people it becomes this
really potent cocktail of neurochemistry
but I want to make sure that everybody
understands the game that you're playing
is a game of neurochemistry right in the
last year at least two billionaires
committed suicide
so I mean like it's heartbreaking When
anybody commits suicide but when
billionaires start committing suicide
like if the answer is not just
self-evident beyond all imagining that
money is not going to solve the problems
that exist between your ears like
there's there's nothing more anyone can
tell you a fool never learns
a smart man learns from his mistakes a
wise man learns from the mistakes of
others on this one I'm begging you be
wise I'm not telling you not to chase
money I'm just saying it's not going to
feed you emotionally the way you think
it is so you've got to completely
Divorce Yourself from this notion of
outcome and become completely obsessed
with the idea of sincere Pursuit
now why sincere Pursuit
the reason to tie your sense of self
your self-esteem your pride your ego
your identity all of that the reason to
tie that to sincere Pursuit is it's the
only part you can control
I cannot promise you that you'll ever be
successful
you cannot promise you that you will be
but you can
promise and know if you actually did it
to show up every day and really pursue
it
you control your mindset
you control how you feel about yourself
nobody can actually get you to feel some
kind of way about yourself
you allow that in right that's like
the cheesiest self-help you're ever
gonna hear but it got cheesy because
it's so true so people repeated it a lot
and if you lose sight of that if you
lose sight of what you allow yourself to
think is going to control you at a
neurochemical level
and at the neurochemical level that's
going to influence then again how you
feel and how you think and then you get
into this death spiral where you're
thinking negative you believe in the
negative which makes you feel badly
about yourself and then you get stuck in
that and you can't get out and you see a
lot of that on the hopes and fears
people afraid they're never going to be
able to break free people in this room
that took the time to write it down that
they were never going to get out of that
negative Loop
and that negative Loop is really real
but here's the thing the negative Loop
is based in biology
and once you begin to understand what
the biology is exactly then you can
begin to take control of your life and
step one in the biological train is to
break the tie that you have between
outcome
and worth
once you begin to break that down then
you can step to naked and raw and say
all right this is just practice
and once you're in that mode of
practicing you're in skill acquisition
mode
and the name of the game is skill
acquisition like it really is sort of
that dull and boring it's just about
getting so good at something that you
can't be denied
and that's one of those things like I'm
gonna say that phrase so much that I
worry that's going to become trite but
that is one of the most
awe-inspiring Notions on the planet
the thought that you could become so
good at something
that you leave people in awe
and when you can leave people in awe you
can do just about anything you want with
your life speaking of this idea of
distribution and um and free-flowing
we're seeing the rise of gig economy
freelance work uh apps like uber that
are having big effects in the world and
including effects on labor and how work
Works any thoughts on what this might
mean moving into the future and
freelance economy well the a key element
is education and it is interesting
in a certain way how
now that we have all you know courses
about almost everything you still have
to pay a little bit for The Learning
Company to get the very best but in math
and science even the free stuff is
extremely good uh that's out there and
yet you know and for early level math we
have Khan Academy and lots of things
that has had a truly modest effect on
actual skill levels and so the
motivational aspects
um you know why do you learn many people
learn just to get a degree because that
is how you get a job but how do you make
things interesting
that's kind of an unsolved problem so I
do view uh you know retraining and
education that in order to deal with the
dynamism of this uh fast-paced
Innovation that you also want to make
equivalent breakthroughs not just in
automating things but improving
education and if you could have one wish
to improve one thing in an economy uh
you know education is kind of the master
switch of your capability there's a few
things like energy instability and trust
that are important too but education
would be uh right up there and yet you
know if I say to you oh the best math
teacher lived 50 years ago he's better
than any math teacher since then you
couldn't disprove that that was right
that is our understanding of how you
draw kids in and how you understand
their misconceptions is it's it's very
ad hoc the average math teacher today is
probably about the same uh as 20 years
ago and yet you know if we can do agents
you know we're talking about the general
issue of being able to read and and form
knowledge the idea being as good as
one-on-one math tutor and seeing what
types of conceptual mistakes people make
and even more importantly understanding
how you motivate them uh to you know
that you keep it at the right level or
you create the right uh sort of problem
domain that they might be interested in
or you know some sort of contest or draw
a social aspect into it that
motivational piece is where you see most
of the variants it's not domain
knowledge uh that uh you know makes
difference as we see because that it's
online and yet uh we don't see much
change so I am enthused about that
whether that means that your learning
will be more episodic and you continue
to do it in adulthood you know that
would be ideal so that even if the job
market is switching your uh qualified I
went skydiving in Dubai right and
skydiving skydiving is a really
interesting confront with fear right so
so I gotta stand up I got to stand up
all right so so
all your friends what happens you go out
how you oh sorry I dropped my thing so
what happens is you go out the night
before and you you know you take a drink
with your friends and somebody says yeah
we should go skydiving tomorrow
and you go yeah we'll go skydiving well
yeah yeah yeah and everybody goes yeah
yeah right and you go home by you by
yourself you're like um
right you're like well yeah I mean they
they was drunk too
right so so maybe maybe they're not
maybe maybe I mean we don't have to go
we don't have to do it so then that
night you're laying in your bed and you
just keep
and you're terrified you keep imagining
over and over again jumping out of an
airplane and you can't figure out why
you would do that right and you lay in
there and you have the worst night's
sleep of your life but you still have
the hope that your friends were drunk
right so you wake up the next day and
you go you know down and you said where
you were going to meet and everybody's
there you're like oh
um all right all right cool cool cool
cool cool right so you get in the van
and you don't know that your friends had
the same night that you had because
they're pretending like they didn't
they're like yeah man my uncle's a Navy
SEAL and you know this is gonna be great
I've been looking forward to this you
like oh my God oh my God and your
stomach is terrible you can't eat and
everything but you don't want to be the
only Punk who doesn't jump out of this
airplane so you get there and then you
have the safety brief and you're
standing there and the guys will tell
you well if the shoot doesn't open
what's going to happen is you doing
what could happen that the shoot the
shoot wouldn't open right so you do a
thing and what you do is your first jump
you're attached to a guy who is going
you know he's gonna walk you out so you
go and you get there and there's an
airplane and nobody's stopping
everybody's still going so you get onto
the airplane and you're sitting there
and and you know it's extra because
you're sitting on some dude's lap some
stranger
sitting on his lap and it's like you
know you're trying to make small talk
yeah man
you know so you do you be jumping with
people all the time huh
right you know so and then you just want
to make sure yo you got you got kids
right you got people you need to see
you just want to make sure he's serious
right so you get in there so
everything's normal so you fly and you
go up you go up you go up you go up to
14 000 feet and you notice there's a a
light it's red and it's yellow and green
right so right now the light's red so
then you start thinking at some point
the light's going to go green because
you don't know what's going to happen
right and you wait and it goes yellow
and the light goes green and somebody
opens the door and in that moment you
realize you've never been in a freaking
airplane with the door open
right Terror oh sorry I'm spitting
oh sorry no terror terror terror terror
right so you go and then you know if
you're if you were smart you sat in the
back so you don't go first right and
then people start going out of the
airplane and you go and the guy walks
you up to the end of the thing and
you're standing and your toes are on the
edge and you're looking out down to
death
and they say on three and they say one
two and he pushes you on two because
people grab on three right
right and you go
and you fall out of the airplane and in
one second you realize that it's the
most Blissful experience of your life
you're flying right it doesn't feel like
falling right it's like you actually are
kind of held a little bit by the wind
and then you start and you you start
falling you've fallen and you there's
zero fear you realize that the point of
Maximum danger is the point of minimum
fear it's Bliss it's Bliss and you're
flying
right and you're doing it and then 20
seconds 25 seconds 40 seconds and you
have enough time to just kind of be like
Ah that's that building that's not like
that one
right you start doing all of that and
the the lesson for me was why were you
scared in your bed the night before
why did you what do you need that fear
for just don't go why are you scared in
your bed 16 hours before you jump why
are you scared in the car
why could you not enjoy breakfast what
what what did you need to fear is fear
of what you're nowhere and even near the
airplane everything up to the stepping
out there's actually no reason to be
scared it only just ruins your day you
don't have to jump and then in that
moment all of a sudden where you should
be terrified is the most Blissful
experience of your life and God placed
the best things in life on the other
side of Terror on the other side of your
maximum fear are all of the best things
in life Amazon one of the things we try
to do is have multiple paths to yes
and so here's here's a little thought
experiment for you
if you are a junior
executive at Amazon and the if we if
Amazon did this in the typical kind of
corporate hierarchy way you had an idea
you need to get your boss
to green light that idea and then your
boss's boss needs to Greenlight that
idea and then your boss's boss's boss
needs to Greenlight that idea there are
probably five levels or more before that
idea gets the go-ahead
Sim instead that you're an entrepreneur
with a startup company idea and you need
venture capital
you go to Sand Hill Road
and you go to the first Venture cap list
and they tell you no and you go to the
second one and they tell you no
you're maybe your 20th one tells you yes
you've got 19 no's and one yes and
you're still good to go
so that that Venture Capital model is
there's multiple paths to yes there were
20 people who could give you a yes and
it didn't matter how many gave you a no
so if you want Innovative thinking you
have to think about how can we get you
want hide you want a large number of
high judgment people empowered to Green
Light things you want multiple pass to
yes you want a system where as a junior
Air Force officer with a good idea
the first five people tell me no and
somehow I can still go pursue that idea
so you got to figure out that's an
organizational
um uh challenge that big organizations
have to figure out a way to do and by
the way I get you know
this happens all the time I'll say I
don't think that's a good idea but
somebody else will green light it and
I'm fine with that because usually the
cost of the experiments is pretty small
things only get expensive when they work
right once something works you're like
Whoa We need to double down on that not
then the spending can get heavy and then
those become big consequential decisions
and that's where the hierarchy and the
using the Judgment of the most senior
people to me this really helps a lot of
experts in AI don't share the same level
of concern that you do about the danger
fools
what what's this last words
what specifically do you believe that
they don't
ah
um well
the biggest issue I see with so-called
AI experts is that they they think they
know more than they do
um
and I think they're smarter than they
actually are in general we are all much
smarter than we think we are but much
less smart dumber than we think we are
um by a lot so
yeah
this is this tends to play plague smart
people
um they just can't they Define
themselves by their intelligence and
they they don't like the idea that a
machine can be way smarter than them so
they discount the idea which is
fundamentally flawed That's The Wishful
Thinking uh situation
um
I'm really quite close to I'm very close
to The Cutting Edge in Ai and it scares
the hell out of me
um
is capable of vastly more than almost
anyone knows
and the rate of improvement is
exponential
you can see this in things like alphago
which went from in the span of maybe six
to nine months it went from being unable
to beat even a reasonably good go player
to then beating the European world
champion who was ranked 600 then beating
Lisa doll four or five
what been world champion for many years
then beating the current world champion
then beating everyone while playing
simultaneously then then there was Alpha
zero
which crushed Alpha go 100 to zero
and Alpha zero just learned by playing
itself
and it can play basically any game that
you put the rules in for if you whatever
rules you give it literally read the
rules play the game and be superhuman
for any game
um nobody expected that rate of
improvement if you ask those so those
same experts uh who think AI is not
progressing at the rate that I'm saying
I think you'll find that their
predictions for things like go and and
other and other uh AI advancements have
the batting average is quite weak it's
not good
um
we'll see this also with uh
with self-driving uh
I think probably by any next year
self-driving will be
will Encompass essentially all modes
driving and be
at least
100 to 200 percent
um safer than a person by the end of
next year
we're talking like maybe 18 months from
now
um and it's a study on on Tesla's
autopilot version one which is
relatively primitive and found that it
was a 45 reduction in highway accidents
and that's despite autopilot one being
just version one
um version two I think will be
at least two or three times better
that's the current version that's
running right now
so the rate of improvement is really
dramatic we have to figure out some way
to ensure that the Advent of digital
super intelligence is one which is
symbiotic with Humanity I think that's
the single biggest existential crisis
that we face and the most pressing one
and how do we do that
I mean if we take it that it's
inevitable at this point some version of
AI is coming down
how do we how do we steer through that
well
I I'm not normally an advocate of
Regulation and oversight I mean I think
once you generally you're on the side of
minimizing those things but this is a
case where you have a very serious
danger to the public
and therefore there needs to be a public
body that
has insight and then oversight on to
confirm that everyone is
developing AI safely
um
like this is extremely important
I think danger of AI is much greater
than the the danger of nuclear warheads
by a lot
um
and nobody would suggest that we allow
anyone to just build nuclear warheads if
they want
that would be insane and mark my words
AI is far more dangerous than nukes
far so why do we have no regulatory
oversight this is insane
what's the question you've been asking
for a long time I think it's a question
that's come to the Forefront of the last
year where you begin to realize that it
doesn't necessarily I think we we've all
been focused in on the idea of
artificial super intelligence right
which is clearly a danger but maybe you
know a little further out what's
happened over the last year is you've
seen artificial what I've been calling
artificial stupidity you can talk about
you know algorithmic manipulation of
social media like we're in it now it's
starting it's starting to happen
how do we how do we is it what's the
intervention at this point
um
I'm not really all that worried about
the short-term stuff things that are
um like narrow AI is not a species level
risk
um
it it will result in dislocation uh in
lost jobs and
you know that sort of better weaponry
and that kind of thing but it is not a
fundamental species level risk uh
whereas uh digital super intelligence is
so it's really all about laying the
groundwork to make sure that
if Humanity collectivity decides that
creating digital super intelligence is
the right move
then
we should do so very very carefully
very very carefully
um
this is the most important thing that we
could possibly do the Dallas Uber driver
oh so as somebody who has gotten into
countless Ubers and some small
percentage of them know who I am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
Alice that's in this book
um I get choked up when I think about
him uh an aha I choked up I get choked
up because
what happens for me every single day
is and you hear from people every single
day you've got millions and millions of
people that are inspired by empowered by
impacted by your content there are
people out there that use your work as a
lifeline and it is humbling
and what I am
really present to in the work that I'm
putting out and the stuff that I'm
sharing whether it's my failures or the
things that I'm using that are helping
me in my own struggles
is just how much people are holding
themselves back
and how much pain people feel
because most folks know what they dream
about
and what they want
and yet they're spending all of their
time and energy arguing against what
they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
I hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment but it's not
going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door
and most people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going I got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
I don't know if I'm worth it I don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this I don't think I'm good enough I
failed so many times I can't go through
that door
and that's the problem I want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you and you are
actively arguing against it you're
bringing yourself down you're beating
yourself out like people will cheer for
you and me they won't cheer for
themselves
I'm the same way and so this Uber driver
the story that you're talking about I
get into the car and we start driving
and I'm on the phone as we're driving
and I'm having a conversation with
somebody about this daytime talk show
that I launched which was a dream with
Sony Pictures Television and then uh was
promptly fired after season one it was a
huge failure because we didn't make it
to season two
huge failure in real world terms massive
success when it comes to the timeline of
my life and so I'm talking to this
person about the talk show I hang up the
phone and this Uber driver comes alive
he's like oh my gosh I can't believe
you're in my cab and I'm like why and he
says because I I want to talk to you
about something I think you can help me
and I'm like great how can I help you
and he says I have a dream of being a
oscar-winning
actor and creating opportunities for
other black and Latino men to do the
same in acting and I'm like freaking
fantastic what the are you doing in
Dallas right yeah the guy's 25 and so I
I go you know the game is in New York
and L.A I mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in Dallas
but why are you not in La why are you
not in New York and he's like you're
right you're right you're right I need
to move to LA like why not
and he says I have seven hundred dollars
in my bank account I'm like that's
freaking fantastic you have 700 in a car
dude drop me off and get driving what
are you waiting for and so we have this
whole conversation and I write about it
in this book where I am actively arguing
for his dream and he is actively arguing
against his dream
and what is so sad is throughout this
conversation Tom he's like you're right
700 could get me there you're right I am
only 25. you're right if I keep thinking
and thinking and thinking and thinking
about what I want to be doing I'm not
only going to drive in circles my whole
life is going to spin in circles as I
think about what I want and I don't do
about it and then you are going to
find yourself not at 25 but at 45 or 65
and you're going to be so filled with
regret that you never put a put a bet on
yourself
and so this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
California and me giving him a bunch of
tools that I talk about in this book and
the point of the story is does he move
or not I don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us we do not
know how to do it for ourselves your
dream is possible the business you want
to build the life that you want to lead
the impact that you want to make it's
possible it really is even if nobody
like you has done it before there are a
million reasons why your idea will not
work and eat why it will which side you
choose to focus on will determine your
life so I'm an introvert that may be
hard to to realize or hard to tell
because when I get on camera when I'm
talking to entrepreneurs I get excited I
get animated but I'm an introvert at
heart I don't talk to people on the
airplane I hate networking events being
in big group causes me anxiety I'm super
awkward and you know don't know what to
say whenever I'm kind of put into a
group I'm not the life of a party I'd
rather be by myself and so I'm very
introverted and I used to believe that
that would be a big roadblock for me if
you look back on on the history of my
helping entrepreneurs as my website and
then my YouTube channel I always hid
behind the famous people I always hid
behind sharing my story because I didn't
think it was relevant or as important or
powerful it's like hey you got this
chance to learn from Elon Musk who cares
about Evan Carmichael and for the
longest time on my channel Evan
Carmichael's top 10 rules of success was
the number one request and it always
blew my mind like why who cares right I
mean all these great stories why does it
matter about me and I was always
reluctant to share my story and I always
felt like
because I'm an introvert
I don't know how this is going to work
out when I when I look to people who've
done it when I look to other people
built Big YouTube channels or great
communicators or fantastic on stage
they look like they have it all figured
out I I love young Les Brown he's my
greatest motivational speaker of all
time when I look at someone like Les
Brown It's hard to imagine him being an
introvert he seems to be always happy
the life of a party has got stories to
share and if I if I want to be like that
I want to be a speaker I always told
myself I can't because I'm introverted
and and he's not and so I don't know how
to bridge the gap and so that's where
you know people like me haven't won
before people like me haven't done it
before at least the ones that I knew of
and so it's easy to say well because it
hasn't been done before now now you
can't do it as well what I discovered
was you know what I still care about
serving I still care about helping I
still want to make a big impact I want
to I want to be able to touch people's
lives even if I don't want to small talk
and chat with them and be the life of a
party and that is possible and once I
shifted it to service once I shifted it
to recognizing that I'm not even here
for me I'm not on stage for me I'm not
in this room for me I'm in this room to
serve and using your perceived weakness
as a strength thinking things like I'm
an introvert so I don't talk much but
I'm a great listener
I'm a fantastic listener I can very
quickly understand what you're going
through and how you're feeling
and now I can use that to make better
content and to help shift you and move
you to where you need to get and those
things of understanding that that I am
service built and so are you
and that just because other people
haven't done it doesn't mean that I
can't really help give me the confidence
belief motivation momentum to keep going
there are always going to be reasons why
you can't win there's going to be a
million reasons right a million reasons
why you can't win and eight why you will
5 8 10 but a smaller amount of reasons
why you will and if you start talking to
your friends and talk to your family and
and compare yourself to other people
you're going to find the same thing of
now there's three million reasons why
you can't win
and it's really just that choice to
figure out which are you going to focus
on the three million reasons why you
can't win or the eight while you can
[Music]
oh I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to learn the money habits of the
wealthy check the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there it's
something I encourage a lot of
entrepreneurs to think about I think a
lot of people they will go from their
full-time job quit they have very meager
savings and suddenly they're like this
has to work well now you've put yourself
in a bad position either start it while
you have a full-time job